I was just recently at the
electromagnetic field festival which is
an amazing hacker maker festival camping
festival though so it's in a field
electromagnetic field
it's a great name it's a quality name
something that they always do at EMF is
they hand out badges and because it's a
maker festival the badges are actually
little electronic devices it's a fairly
sophisticated machine it's got a lot of
features obviously it has the screen but
it also has Wi-Fi it in fact has an app
library and these are all downloaded
over the Wi-Fi and installed like let's
install er let's install a game should
we do pong yeah okay yeah yeah so I get
it move my bat by tilting yeah oh dear
I'm losing ah most of these apps were
developed actually at the festival or
shortly afterwards and the reason that
it was so easy to make all of these apps
is because the board uses micro Python
which is something which I hadn't used
before and I thought and with there's no
computer file video about it so I
thought I would just talk a little bit
about it as a way of programming
microcontrollers so the most common like
hobby small computing type things are
obviously the Arduino and the Raspberry
Pi the Arduino is designed to be
extremely easy to use and it is relative
to the microcontrollers that came before
it but you still have to write C code
which is not the easiest language for
beginners to pick up it's got a few
complexities and some gotchas there
which any language has but yeah see see
is a C is a tricky language in many ways
whereas this is a microcontroller that
you can program in Python and so
previously if you wanted to have a small
computer running Python probably the way
you do it is to use a Raspberry Pi but a
Raspberry Pi obviously is a much
big a deal it's a fully-fledged computer
you can put a real operating system on
there or even something like Windows if
you wanted to I don't I don't judge you
know if you wanted to do that your own
roasting pie in your own time
behind closed doors you know it's fine
but the point is having a whole
operating system is just a whole bunch
of extra complexity which is unnecessary
for a lot of small microcontroller type
tasks so it's nice to have a system that
you can literally just put a Python file
on and it runs directly with no
appreciable operating system underneath
it's just Python and microcontroller it
was a Kickstarter a couple of years ago
they developed this interpreter to allow
Python to run on microcontrollers and
then also a board specifically designed
for this which you can buy but it's open
source so there are a few different
boards that can run it and including
this the tilde but obviously you can't
buy these I don't think you only get
them by going to EMF so it's kind of a
bit like the Arduino model is it all
though right quite similar to an Arduino
yeah anyone could buy everyone could
make their own but sometimes it might be
easier just to buy one but they're
making or something like that um yeah
yeah and it's just it's like a standard
I suppose okay that once you once that's
defined then anybody can make their own
chip or they can port micro Python to a
different chip and there's there's a
bunch of different boards that it can
run on let's just write hello world to
type an application you just plug it in
with USB this actually want to use to
charge my phone this is the thing I like
about this actually is the simplicity of
it you plug it in it just registers
itself just like a memory stick or
anything else that you've plugged in as
USB storage and then you get you know a
directory just dump a Python file in
there
I think call it main dot py and it will
run it and that's that's all there is to
it with the tilde with this badge tilde
is like the name of the bar yes previous
ones were actually shaped like a tilde
character and yeah because it has this
app system it
little bit more complicated but not much
you just have to make your Python file
in a particular directory and give it a
little header the standard thing for an
Arduino is blink right where you have
the LED and you turn it on and off every
half second that's the tutorial thing so
let's do that fill in some details here
I am Robert Myles this program will be
called hello world there's a sort of a I
don't know if you'd call it an operating
system there's a little interface that
the badge comes with that lets you
navigate through and select which app
you want to launch and that kind of
thing so it needs to know what the app
is called and that kind of thing if you
get a regular like a pie board the one
from the Kickstarter or any of those
they I believe you just put the file on
and it runs it and that's the end of it
here's the head of stuff and then we're
importing a library pi B is this library
which contains stuff for interacting
with the board's Hardware so we're just
initializing this LED variable to be LED
one this little one the one next to the
one that's currently flashing LED a and
then we just have a while loop toggle
the LED wait five hundred milliseconds
which is half a second and that is it
all we need to do is put this file in a
directory called you know hello world or
whatever in the app directory and that's
it save that unmount it very important
to safely remove Hardware you know don't
just yank out your USB devices
willy-nilly usually I'd say life is too
short for that kind of thing but and
there we are so now we're running it the
light is blinking success but obviously
this board is capable of a lot more it's
got this nice screen let's let's put
something on the screen again there's
this nice graphics library you have to
initialize it and then I think you can
just do this is this is from from memory
I think you just do that and then you
give it the coordinates you want to
write at the text and the color which
are just in there is constants and I
think that
should do it so we restart the board and
then we can just unedited this on the
board itself like this file I have it
open on the external drive which is the
board so you can do all of your
development right there on the board
unmount it again restart yeah and now it
says hello world and the blinking light
still so it's really that simple and you
know Arduino is pretty simple but this
is easier and then of course you have
the Python language which is a wonderful
you know powerful and easy to use
language which I highly recommend to
anyone the board itself has a bunch of
features firstly output pins for all
kinds of different things
so the idea is you can use this board
much like you would an Arduino to drive
some other electronics these connectors
around the edge here are designed for
conductive thread so if you wanted to
make some kind of clothing that does
something fancy with your badge built
into it you can do that somewhat
bizarrely these contacts here are for
for servo motors so you could drive
servos with it there's four of them if
you wanted to make a drone possibilities
are endless
it's the zombocom of boards you know the
only limit is yourself and there's a
competition for people who enter EMF -
who can do the coolest thing with the
badge before next time I'm not sure if
I'm going to enter that but I did try
making an app I've made I wrote a
solitaire game because I was having fun
with the graphics libraries and I wanted
to see Michael drew all the different
cards and stuff I don't like solitaire
so I only did the best bit this is thing
this is the good bit of solitaire the
bouncing cards so we've got a Windows
3.1 references makes dimly wargames
mixed in with yeah it's your sense of
humor yeah exactly I just wanted to see
if I could do it so if you drew on those
cards and everything or they in the
library um no yeah this is all in fact
these are all drawn with the basic
drawing functions so fill rectangle or
polygons that kind of thing simple I can
show you the program actually this is my
solitaire program so they're the same
delay function we were using before and
define the cards I don't have face cards
yet the I don't have the Jack queen and
king that requires more artistic skill
than I'm able to bring to bear right now
and also the thing I like about it right
now is it's one file I don't have any
external images to copy in or anything
basic stuff you know it's not none of
it's complicated and you expose the
plastic at the surface in particular
regions according to the pattern and the
important thing is when this particular
polymer is exposed to light it becomes
soluble if the regions that aren't
exposed aren't soluble so then you